uh
my name is claudia valencia i am the
chair of the council on latin american
and liberian studies of the mcmillan
center here at yale
i am delighted to welcome you to the
first
colloquium of our colloquium series now
we are going
to be virtual for the rest of the
semester and
i am particularly honored to launch this
series
with yale pointer fellow and former war
fellow
paul coarcharia and
before i do a full and deserving
introduction
to paola let me tell you a little bit
about
claise we have recently updated our
mission statement that now greets clies
enhances the understanding of latin
america
and the iberian peninsula through
collaborative efforts focused on
meaningful partnerships an exchange of
ideas
and academic research so notice
two key words collaborative and
partnership
which are the things that
we will be stressing uh through
the the year uh at class
so basically clice is the central hub
for
intellectual exchange and partnership
partnerships in latin america spain and
portugal
and with our first talk and especially
with paola as our inaugural speaker
i am excited to kick off the this year's
theme which is deconstructing gender
in latin america so just a brief
update on that we have some exciting
developments
around this theme we are launching the
latin american
interdisciplinary gender network
which we are doing in partnership
with the universidad national autonoma
mexico through the center of research on
gender studies this year
and the center for mexican studies in
boston
the inaugural virtual conference that
will formally launch
this research network is slated to be
later in november okay without further
ado let me now
introduce paula paula
is a chilean journalist editor and
author
and she's also a professor at
universidad diego portales
and a member of the board of the young
global leaders foundation
and of comunidad mujer she's also the
co-founder
and director of the women and media
chair
at universidadio portales and a member
of the council
of the west gender parity initiative in
chile
she was named a young global leader in
2006
a yale world fellow in 2011
won the lenka for a new league award for
the best
woman journalist in chile in 2014
and was chosen chosen one of the bbc 100
inspiring women in 2015
and in in 2019 she won
with together with her team the
excellence in journalism award
in print media in chile for their
coverage of sexual misconduct
and abuse she apolo paula studied
journalism
at the university of catholica de chile
and has a master's degree
in comparative literature furthermore
paola has published six non-fiction
books in one of them
she interviewed all chilean presidents
after the return to democracy
she is the former magazine editor of el
mercurio
former editor of chief of cara's
and former editorial editor of televisa
group in chile
she has also written for the huffington
post
so i could go on the entire
hour listing her accomplishments and
awards and
publications but let me wrap up by
saying that we are
truly thrilled to welcome paola and i'm
going to ask the audience if
you have questions to use the chat box
and i will read the questions at the end
of paula's presentation
so welcome paula and you can begin thank
you
thank you claudia thank you so much for
this wonderful
introduction uh it's really really an
honor for me to
to be with you today um
i think that uh my my semester at the
yale world fellows program
uh in in 2012 was really one of the best
moments uh of my professional and
personal life
so i'm very grateful to you claudia to
danielle to asia
and to class for inviting me today
and also for the yale welfare program
which is
which is something that you become in a
certain year but you remain for your
whole life
and i'm also grateful to universidad de
corportales where i teach
and i run this chair on women and media
so i thank you all for being here today
i will begin
my presentation today
because as you as you might
as it is the case in in so many places
in the world
this pandemic has been really a very
very
hard problem for women so coronavirus
has
a gender uh has has uh
we can say has unveiled a lot of gender
issues that were there
they were before the pandemic that by
they have really become
more deep more deep more uh relevant
and really really uh important to
address
especially in latin america where now we
are living
under this uh really uh
bad face of the coronavirus and what i'm
going to tell you about is
what is happening in chile but i think
this is also what is happening in many
many places of the world and especially
in latin america
where i am so um
you know so many authors and other
journalists and other writers and other
you know op-eds all over the world has
addressed the same thing that i'm
telling you today that
covet 19 has unveiled and worsened every
gender inequality in chile and latin
america
so uh what are we going to do now about
this
is something that i want us all together
to reflect on
at the end of my presentation and maybe
with your questions we can we can
develop
furthermore talking about solutions
and what happened in chile at least
before covet 19 well we were having a
great moment
related to gender fights uh
you know this this is a picture of the
historic uh eighth eighth of march
uh demonstration
i was there also i was with with my
daughters
and uh if you can read i don't know if
you understand
uh spanish but you can breed there you
know
between all these women that were there
says historicas which was means
historical
so for all of us women marching that day
the international women's day uh all
over the the world and especially in
chile was
millions and millions of women you know
from all ages
women with kids women you know with
their grandmothers
women you know friends uh couples you
know
it it was really a a massive
and marvelous party uh where all women
children we
were together saying that we have
reached a point
where we could say that all of us
together
were historical so meaning that
what we were doing was making history
so this was uh a painting in the
actually in the street now was taken
away during the coronavirus they decided
to make a lot of renovations
on the on the public places and they you
know i don't know if it was
delivered or not but this was erased
but this is the the spirit where we are
living
millions of people there millions of
women it was a
uh you know a moment of uh
genuine complicity sorority of children
women from
as i was telling you different ages
different professions different
backgrounds
we were all in the same boat feeling
that
progress was being made and and we had
ahead of us
a better future for us but also for our
daughters
and our grandchildren and eighth of
march
coronavirus was already you know in
india
in a lot of places in the us certainly
and in chile too the first case
was um in the 3rd of march
so at that point i think there were i
don't know 10 cases in chile they were
really
you know uh contained so
we were able to march that day without
feeling that we could be
uh we could be we could get the disease
so it was we i can say the last chance
we had the last moment where children
people could go to the streets
again and and all as i told you all
women saying we are all in this together
and we are making historical progress
and uh you know these are some of the
pictures of that day
uh there were you know artists there
were
a different kind of of performances of
different
groups of chilean women saying and now
you know
this i don't know how to tell you what i
felt there but
what i think it it's something like uh
the strongest sorority that i have ever
felt in a demonstration
of women and or any kind of
demonstration in chile
but also the the sense of hope
especially of young women like this one
and they were like vegan powered
feeling as i was telling you that the
future was right in front of us
we just have to you know move forward
and also you might see have seen this
this uh this picture because it's it's
now a global
chilean uh group called las tesis
uh which is you know this this this
amazing women
that i have now uh
realized that time magazine has uh
chosen them
like one of the most the 100 influential
people on earth
recently like yesterday or today
this group of chilean women chilean
artists
and performers they have created this
global
uh song that is called a rapist in in
in your in your way and uh so after the
the chilean social upheaval
these women you know created this song
this
the choreography that now is a global
uh a global sign i can say
much more than a performance is a global
sign of
women uh fighting together to have
uh freedom independence uh to have
the you know to really um make
uh a reality uh to to live
without fear to live without violence
and to understand that
it's not us that we have to change not
chilean women or children all over the
world that have
sung this song it's it's a structure is
the
is the structure how society is built
that has to change
it's not us that have to change is is
this patriarchy culture that has made
for some men not all of them of course
that have the the idea or the illusion
that they can do whatever they want with
us with our bodies with our lives
and and make us fearful but now you know
with this
uh this sense of empowerment also and
this sense of pride for children women
what because what la stasis have done
has
made us all proud of you know this song
coming from a small country from chile
it's gone viral in in you know in few
hours
and you know people you know all over
the world
uh have a song this this this
this song and uh um i was telling you
and um and the on the letter it's
the lyrics is really you know something
that moves me
illa gulpanovia
so the fault is not mine where i was not
how i
was dressed and this is very important
because violence
against women in all the degrees
you know from the micro machismo that we
can
suffer every day you know fro till
you know being raped and being abused in
the workplace
by bosses by people on the streets it's
a
huge a global problem and from chile we
were
we are still so proud that we had found
a way
to make women more empowered by the of
course the
the power and the the the strength of
art so and here is uh
you know people in turkey congress women
in turkey uh
singing this song and also in different
places and then
you know there was a huge process in
turkey that was repressed
by the government of women saying you
know singing this song and also saying
we are not going to
accept this kind of treatment anymore in
the world
so imagine how was for us
uh that moment so this you know this
big eight of march event then you know
all what la teses has brought to all
chilean women in the sense of being more
empowered
more uh you know all the solidarity from
all over the world and the pride
and then the third part of the good news
from chile before the coronavirus
came here was that after the social
upheaval
of 18 of october almost a year from
ago that you must have read in the
newspapers and all that
of people demanding uh you know a better
way of living and a better way of
uh relating to to the state more freedom
more
social rights and all that led to
historic moments
where all the political parties most of
them in the congress
uh this they signed uh an agreement
to uh uh organize a referendum that is
going to be
in you know a month from now
uh so that chilean people has to decide
whether they want to write a new
constitution which is
you know the institutional solution that
the chileans thought that was important
to address
this social upheaval and this social
crisis
and the good thing is that with the help
of a lot of you know
ngos that promotes women's rights and a
very
transversal group of women from
different political parties grounds
agents etc
one of them comunidad mujero it's it's
one of the most important ngos in chile
promoting women's right and the vice
president so i'm very proud of
belonging to this organization from the
beginning of it
was one of the leading parts of
promoting that this new constitution
had to be written with gender parity you
know in
a country you i don't know how much do
you know the extent of machismo
in in our countries in latin america i'm
certain that claudia knows about this
uh but we live in in a in a region that
it's some
it's a marvelous it's a it's a great
region in so many things
but related to machismo patriarchy we
are very very left behind and we're
so far away from developed countries in
so many issues
um and and machismo is something that we
experiment
in it on a daily basis but
this you know accomplishment of having
been able to
uh to uh make this agreement that the
new
constitution if you know chilean people
accept
as all the polls are are are showing
that
we're going to write a new constitution
then you know half of the the
conventionals
are going to be women and that is also
was a huge
uh success for chilean women
and so this is a picture of that day and
it you can read there says
si nosotras so without us never again
so that means we're going to be part of
the public scene for
you know now on uh you know forever so
it's it's uh
it's not only like uh uh being able to
succeed in this moment in the
constitutional moment we are going to be
part of the debate on a gender parity
basis
from our from now on and uh the you know
the
complicity sorority collaboration
between women
as i tell you from different part of the
social
and political arena in chile was was key
to to achieve that so women together we
can achieve whatever we want
so then as i told you the third of march
covered arrived in chile so at the
beginning we were really
we didn't really believe i think no one
really believed that
we were going to suffer uh like what
they were suffering in china for example
we were
you know i remember reporting that the
news of people being confined and locked
downs and
everything that happened in gujan and
then you know in europe
but we really thought that was not going
to happen to us
i don't know why we thought that way so
you know it was okay there's a
preparation
there's going to be different uh
measures taken back by governments by
the ministry of health
so that we don't face any kind of
situation like
don't don't have you know beds uh
in the hospitals for very sick people
and all that but besides of older people
being
more worried we thought it was going to
be like i don't know two
two weeks or one month uh moments of
being very very careful
and that was it but it was not the case
you know chile
at one moment one of the was one of the
10
one of the ten countries with worse
numbers
related to the amount of of people with
the disease
per million of of citizens
and related to the deaths of of people
per millions of
citizens so we had a really really we
have had
because we are it's not over yet we have
had uh
really awful very very bad moments
related to the covet
and its influence of course in sanitary
and health issues but
also with what happened with women which
is what i'm going to tell you
so the other pandemic as so many authors
and myself
included we think it's the other
pandemic began with
the lockdowns and the schools closed you
know the schools were closed completely
in chile until this moment i mean
only very few schools have been allowed
to open
in in regions of chile that have no
cases
but you know 98 of schools are still
you know closed from march 16th
you know it's being all these months
without school without day cares
and without uh kindergarten for kids so
we haven't had even not even for
people working in the health
in the health forces even then they
don't have
where to take to leave their kids safely
and so that created of course enormous
stress
for women that have to you know work at
the same time of
home school kids and also make all the
the domestic
chores in the house and uh so what
happened you know
and a very strong rise in violence
against women
you know historical rights awful women
being beaten by
by their you know by by their husbands
for their partners
uh women you know almost uh
you know femicidious also and mistreated
and psychological violence
all the degrees of violence against
women in the rice
200 percent more calls for emergency
numbers uh by the ministry of
women in chile two hundred percent rise
which is
unbelievable two stress
i'm i'm certain that might be the case
in the us and all over the world this is
a global problem but
it is my understanding that all not all
the states of the us have closed
all the schools and especially that some
have not closed day cares for example
as happens happen here daycares are not
allowed to open so i mean they are
waiting for the
you know go go to new phases so we can
open again
and uh in the front length of the health
of course women 70 of the health force
is is women so as you can see it's uh
i mean it's it's you know most nurses
are women a lot of doctors and they have
to be there
worrying for their health and without
safe places to leave their kids so
a lot of them have have to you know take
their kids and leave them with their
grandparents but
not see them anymore because
grandparents of course
are the groups at risk
and finally and very very uh sadly
uh historic backlash on in women's
employment
and uh okay this is some of the projects
that all over the world because it's
it's my understanding and and and what i
have reported that this
has happened also in argentina this has
happened in mexico
this in colombia in spain in great
britain
and other countries like france have to
you know
develop very very fastly
places to take women as in chile they
have created albergues
where they take women from home at the
moment
they call so you know police will get in
in the house and take the women and the
kids away and so they remain in this
shelter
but you know being in a shelter during
the pandemic is very very hard i mean
what do they do with the kids they don't
have schools
and they can't apply for a job so it's
really a situation that has created
enormous enormous
problems for women suffering this
violence and
the fact that their perpetrators are
living with them under the same roof has
unveiled all this violence that was
repressed in in this in these households
and mascarilla de si nueve is a project
of the ministry of of women which is
a way to help them because some of them
reported that
uh they they couldn't call the police
they couldn't go
to police stations they couldn't make an
official
denounce they couldn't make of an
official complaint
because they were not allowed to get out
of home because of lockdowns
and for the perpetration would be very
suspicious if they left home
for with no reason so in the in the drug
stores in the pharmacies
if a woman will ask for mascara 19 means
you know for the for the person all over
the counter counter
that she's in danger suffering violence
so he will call the police
and uh so this is you know it's a it's a
very interesting and good project and is
i know that it's in other places i think
in spain
was the first one that that did this so
different kind of ways another you know
thing that they did
was using whatsapp not the phone to to
you know to send a what's up to
uh the policemen or to the ministry or
you know all the different kind of
places helping women in this moment
well the juggling for four jobs the
second problem uh
it's being terrible some women are
reporting
very high levels of depression and
anxiety related to this
uh 42 percent of women in chile are jeff
as their
so they are in charge of their home and
31
are you know only only women households
so imagine what is for a woman if she's
the main great breadwinner of a home
and has to do the work remotely which is
has a lot of
you know problems to do uh with the kids
at home without school and also has to
homeschool them
children they don't understand why you
know they are home and
they are not allowed to be with their
parents all the time and
um the other big problem is that in
chile you know
internet access is is very um
low in poor households so i think
the figure is like only 30 percent of
poor children had
internet access that allowed them really
to
you know attend school so these kids are
also left behind educationally
and um well of course the lockdown
effects
you know are are terrible you know from
the point of view of the the work they
come they can do
some of them a lot of them lost their
jobs and they were the main
breadwinners and uh also
i don't know what's um i would like to
to to understand what happens
in in the us but um
you know in chile men report
you know in the in the reality and in
the in in all the studies that have
been done there is these times
they do little or non domestic and
parental work
so i want to read you a study made by
universidad catolica
revealed that 71 of men
dedicated zero zero hours
to domestic and parental work during a
week
when this poll was made in july so
0 71 so you can understand
here in in our region and in chile
corresponsibility
the idea that you know you share
all the the parental domestic work with
your partner is
is is non-existent so that is one of our
biggest
problem to to to really being able to
put more women on the workforce
and with the pandemic all these women as
i'm going to tell you at the end you
know
some of them were left behind until a
vaccine
proves uh efficient and kids are allowed
to go back to school again
and all this system of care is in place
and uh so chilean men so far related to
this
poll made by universia catolica they
really didn't
behave very well during the pandemic and
some of them even they they say that
it's been very nice to be home
with the kids and all that but they
don't see that this invisible
amount of job of domestic and parental
job
is on the shoulders of women that are
juggling as this
this uh this artist that i put you here
and that we can see in the streets in
chile i don't know if you have been here
but
one of our originalities as a country is
that
in every corner there are people
juggling and then they ask for money
it's a little performance that they do
you know waiting when you wait for the
for the green light and uh every time i
see that
i think okay this is a country where
women we are all all
the time juggling and so it's not that
you know
strange that we have this in our corners
in every corner
of santiago and the regions of chile and
uh so this is one of the you know big
big problems that we are facing
in chile stress but also lack of
employment and a very difficult
and very very strong difficult to go
back to the workforce
well women are you know at the front
line of health services in philly it's
70 percent
and nurses you know the last uh
you know the last uh university econ
says that 77.9 of
uh women studying uh to being nurses is
women
so uh you know we we're seeing these
women they're heroic
they're historical but most of them
have been suffering not only burnout
stress
and all these uh very tough diseases
related to what they have
seen and and you know the amount of work
they have to do
but because they have to they have had
to leave their kids behind
and some of them for months have not
been able to see them or their parents
and and that's you know something that
is really really
hurting them and i have interviewed them
for different projects and
and and what they have suffered is
something really really unbearable
and finally and and and probably the
the you know one of the problems that is
that is going to have an effect on all
the other problems that
we are discussing now is the historic
rising unemployment
and uh so i want to tell you the exact
figures now
and um you know uh
first of all women the the laws of
employment
which is something that women and men
are suffering all over the world because
of the pandemic
well women are suffering much more than
men
first second 88
of women that left the workforce because
of the covet 19
are not applying for a job they are not
looking for a job again
because they don't have you know
daycares schools to put the kids there
safely so you know 88 of the women that
that yet that are unemployed are not
even looking for a job
so this is something dramatic
and uh and and if we if we
and now i'm going to to to finish my
presentation
if we don't do anything if we leave
the reactivations policy that chilean
governments and governments all over the
world are developing are creating
implementing
if they don't have a gender
factor if they don't address what women
are suffering
if they don't face this and if they
don't
give solutions then it's going to happen
what has
happened in chile that the backlash is
of 10 years
related to women in the workplace so now
the numbers of women
participating in the workforce which was
i have to say very low
compared to oecd and to
to the region even before the kovic 19.
so now we are with the with the figures
uh that we had 10 years ago so now 41.3
percent of women
participate in the labor force and
before covet was
52 percent so it's it this is
something it's a it's a problem it's a
dramatic backlash
that might hurt generations of women
women that have lost their jobs now but
also
women that are not going to be able to
look for a job um
for the first time and some of them are
being
you know are getting out of universities
because they have to take care of small
brothers and sons you know so the family
what is happening inside families that
you know is the is the
the girl that is studying that has to
you know postpone their studies to take
care of the children at home
or to help the grandmother or to do all
the care
you know the invisible and and so
important and so key
care at work that women have done all
over the
millennia and that kovid 19 has now
shown how important it is
and uh but we are we are being left
behind but this this is a very beautiful
photo that i want to
to show you to finish my presentation
and to be open to to
to discuss this and to talk it's by
tamara medino a
very distinguished chilean photographer
is she and her mother
and so it's um i think it's very moving
because they are both taking care you
know protecting themselves from kobe but
not protecting themselves from each
other and i think the only way that we
are going to face all these
enormous problems that kavit 19 has
posed
on us is together as we were before kobe
19
and fighting for for this world to
change and um
it is very uh it's a it's a very strange
contradiction that
uh nine from the 12
best leaders world leaders that dealt
with kavy 19 in the different countries
nine of them are women as a former
chilean president mitchell bachelet and
now
uh high commissioner for human rights
have said
so if nine of 12 of the world leaders
that led this
well we're women so women leadership
should be on the rise right but what i'm
telling you in my presentation
is is like is the other way around so
why
the world is even though is seeing how
uh women's leadership can really
address and face all the challenges but
at the same time it's not helping them
to you know be present in the public
arena to be
there in the public sphere because what
it what what
what is happening is really that at
least in chile
they are sending women back home so
thank you so much
and now i'm i'm ready to to talk to you
thank you
well i think i'm gonna represent your
audience and give you
a much deserved applause i i
really thank you for this sovereign
message i think it's such
a tragedy that the momentum
the chilean women were getting in
in march with all the the marches and
demonstrations was cut short and
reversed
set back i don't know how many steps
back so
that that's really tragic so
i'm gonna start reading the questions
from the audience
so the first one is from andy liu and
it reads thanks so much for this
wonderful talk paola
i was wondering when you talk about the
plight of women in chile undercover
domestic violence there is a universal
unspoken assumption
that one every woman is heterosexual
two every woman is in a heterosexual
nuclear family with a man with children
i was wondering is there such a thing as
an lgbtq
gay community in chile do they are
not exist any alternative family
arrangements in chile other than the
traditional heterosexual nuclear family
or heterosexual marriage thanks so much
thank you andy well thank you claudia
thank you andy for your great question
and i think well i have to tell you
first that
women that are facing violence they are
suffering violence is from men not from
other women not i mean it's not a
problem within the
the gay or lgbtq community uh
because what we are seeing in the in
these reports
and the the calls for help they make is
because
their male partner is the one that is
threatening them
or abusing them or beating them not the
not the
the the women partner and of course
there is a very strong
and lgbtq community in chile that has
made
enormous progress in the sense of giving
them
all the rights they deserve but i have
to tell you that we have our legislation
is
really really discriminative to them
we have aguero during civil which means
it's a way of
it's it's it's um you know they can do
this agreement
that is like a marriage but gay marriage
is not
legal in chile until now which is you
know
something that even this president said
that was part of his agenda
for his new government but it's not
being able to
to to pass that law and even though
foundations like iwalis
or mobile have you know given this
fought
this fight you know for years and even
though chilean people and children's
citizens
you know in very high
majority are for gay marriage to be
legal
but we have a a strong uh conservative
even if it's a minority a very strong
conservative
uh parties that they fight this so
that's why
uh gay marriage is not it's not legal in
chile but
they can have this aguardonian civil and
um and their issues now i mean what they
are fighting for
is for having the full rights that they
deserve
us as a couple and also they have to
have the right to adopt
because also you know uh homo parental
adoption is not legal in chile
and what we have seen in chile which is
you know very chilean
is that uh some you know two mothers
they they went
and they registered the kids uh the kid
at the
the civil registration service with two
mothers
and then one judge accepted that so and
then
you know this is one kid i wrote about
him and
it's a very important case in chile and
it was this year
he has two mothers it's historical
because in chile it's not
uh it is not legal and at that moment
there was a lot of criticism from
conservative parties and conservative
conservative leaders saying that
you know this registro civilian chile
was going outside the law
that it was not uh should not be
accepted so
uh you know to to wrap up my answer
lgbtq community in chile is very strong
they they are very active they have made
enormous progress in
a it's not a conservative is a society
that has a minority conservative
minority that has
that is very powerful still
gay marriage is not legal homo parental
adoption
neither and related to uh
domestic violence i'm speaking about uh
heterosexual couples because it's
it's the male against the women it's not
also the other way around it's not women
beating men
it could be the case but it's not i mean
it's women desperate
because they're the man they live with
whether it's the husband or not
is threatening their lives and uh well
you know violence in general
um it's men that do that i mean it's
it's it's not all all men are violence
but it's
it's something that uh plays that way
here thank you paola and thank you andy
for your question i'm gonna go to
madison madison
mcmahon asks thank you for the
presentation
how does this gender crisis fit in the
upcoming vote on
a new constitution do chilean women
see this as an opportunity to make
needed changes
or have they lost faith in the
government's ability to help them
it's a great question because you know
in chile we're leaving historical
moments we are
going to to vote in this referendum
we are going to have a referendum an
election yama referendum
uh in the pandemic so it's going to be
difficult but
we are all promoting that people
participate and go there and use the
masks
and and do the same that other countries
have done like
south korea is one of the the stars
in vis-a-vis voting with the with the
pandemic
and it's very important because as i was
telling you
we all of us we had this enormous
success
that you know the new constitution is
going to be written with gender parity
so you know the cons if the new
constitution
uh passes i mean it's the referendum
says abruevo
a new constitution then the for a year
and a half
uh the conventionales which is the
people that are going to be
chosen in april to to write this new
constitution to make this debate
half of them have to be women you know
it's a quota it's not a quarter even
it's parity it's 50 50.
and i have to tell you at the moment
when all this was
discussing and and there was so many
things at risk in the moment with this
huge
uh you know social process on the
streets there was also violence there
was
a polarization that was very very hard
uh it was like a dream thinking that you
know
seeing the future we could be able uh
all the
the the women in chile to to succeed in
in this
request of having gender parties so we
we we ask for gender parity for
something not only to have a beautiful
picture
50 50 because we want certain things to
be clear in the constitution
that all the respect women's rights are
constitutionally
uh you know uh put there they have to be
written there
and that a lot of things that might be
like okay
you know men or women are equal but we
need that to be in the in the most
important uh legal test text
of a nation which is the constitution to
be
there like okay how is it going to be
that we women are going to be
you know having the same opportunities
the same rights
as men in a country where as as you can
say
a lot of women are out of the workforce
the men don't do their domestic and
parental work
only six percent of women are in boards
you know and
and and and so on and so forth so this
is the moment or
all the things that we have been
fighting for ages are going to be
put in the right place so that we can
see a better future
in front of us uh you know a future that
not not only fairer for women but for
all citizens of course for the lgbt
community
but also for all the misrepresented uh
groups of chile you know we have
indigenous people mapuche they have
you know a lot of rabies vacations they
they really need
a constitution that embraces them our
indigenous
uh members and and and so many other
groups in chile that have been
misrepresented as in in so many
countries
because white male uh
older men are what you mostly see when
you when you when you see where the
you when you see the places where
decisions are taken
hey thank you so much there was a
question by risha that
i think you answered it already but it
doesn't if that's not the case rishabh
please
ask again or or a different question
there is a question by michael
or ortslanky chile in recent years
has had a woman president and a high
percentage of women cabinet minister and
legislators
has this had a positive impact on
chilean women's
in terms of policies loss and quality of
life
that's a great question because as you
know we had
you know the only person that has been
president twice is michelle bachelet is
the first
woman president the only women president
and she she was chosen twice
and also she's she's a global leader i
mean she's a great
uh leader in chile and now she lives in
geneva because she works for the united
nations as i was telling you as high
commissioner for human rights
and um and she's a global leader uh
in topics about you know women's rights
but also
human rights in general because i think
women's rights it's
human rights it's not something that
women are fighting for
for themselves for their own sake it's
about really
you know having a a full citizenship
with
rights for everyone and when she was
president it had a huge
impact i have to tell you that the first
time she became president
you know there was this beautiful image
the day she took office i was reporting
in the streets
and they were selling these presidential
bans that in chile we put you know that
the brazilian puts the presidential vans
and they were you know selling them in
the streets
and there were a lot of women especially
older women with the band
like you know it was just so nice moment
when women were
feeling uh that uh
it was not only michelle bachelet that
was in you know elected it was
we were all with her going to la moneda
which is the presidential palace
she had very strong policies towards uh
helping and promoting women's rights
and she she was very you know concerned
about parity she put parity in all the
in the boards of all the
uh state owned companies for example and
huge success about that all this
this company has thrived with this
parity
uh decision that she made even though at
the beginning they were saying no
you know these companies are going to
suffer why this has to be married
as if you know if women are put in that
position they don't have the merit i
mean
what what's what's the point of course
there are women that are completely
capable of doing the job it's only that
there they have been left behind and
half of the population are normally you
know then they don't even see if there's
a candidate in half of the population
and she also had the other part in the
cabinet and in so many positions she was
very worried of
not only that she was a leader that to
open
the door for more leaders which is
something that is really important that
we all women
well women do you know to get to certain
positions to open the doors for more
women not to
be happy because we are there and we
broke a glass ceiling and then so what
it's
it's only one you need really uh you
know more women to change
otherwise it's only one that normally
they put one just to be
to have a better picture not only of all
white men so
and and she was very very uh active in
that
but then you know uh the next government
was
uh president pineda he's also the second
uh he's only his second period and um
and uh he reversed that policy he he
didn't have
a gender parity uh cabinet
he is not something that he's part of
his uh
his uh really we can say priorities i'm
not saying that he's not worried about
that
you can see that in all the his speeches
and things like that the ministers
but if you really see the priorities
it's not one of the priorities to put
women in position
positions of power and to change the
imbalances and inequalities
gender related and uh and the
bachelorette came again to power the
same thing new promotion new women
and but then in this government we have
seen also this backlash and i'm waiting
for the
proposals of this government especially
from the minister of finance
if he's going to really address uh
erectile
reactivation and economical activation
uh
really taking care and addressing the
gender inequalities that kovidis
19 has and paid so far it's not the case
i mean
there's nothing especially for women
even though you can see that the
situation is really
dramatic especially for the ones that
are the main breadwinner of their
households and also for the other ones
that with their money
i mean it was the you know half of the
what the house will have
uh so they are now you know going to
poverty
um that employment in chile is rising to
levels
not staying in 40 years and it's a very
very hard situation so
i would say that michelle bachelet is a
huge inspiration was
still is a lot of things changed because
you saw a woman president
but you have to make it like you know
very clear
i don't know if in a legal
constitutional
uh way so that it not depends
whether it's someone that really cares
about women's rights or not
who is in power if these things get
maintained in the years ahead or
or if they suddenly get this backlash
and
and and you go from you know to where
you were before that
great thank you so much that was yeah a
very detailed question
i'm sure michael is satisfied with that
uh thank you michael and now going to
alonso velazquez
uh chile is among the highest income
countries in latin america
where are you able to compare chile to
other countries in latin america in this
topic
of domestic abuse and see if it's even
worse in other countries
well it is my uh in my reporting what
i've seen is that
all all this uh rising domestic violence
is a global problem i mean it's happened
also in europe in
in very developed countries and also in
in the region
uh i'm you know i can tell in argentina
there were 18 femicides during the first
20 days of quarantine which is you know
something really really strong
that the first day of quarantine of
lockdown 41 women denounce violence
gender violence in buenos aires uh until
july there were 80 femicides in the
country
uh only considering the months of the
pandemic
and in mexico the calls to these uh
these phone
uh numbers right they had a rise of
sixty percent
and also the petitions to go to
albergues they were they they had a rise
of
30 percent in the national uh
net of shelters and uh and in colombia
the same
phone number emergency phone number
received more than
91 percent of goals so i think it's
it's really uh a global problem
uh you know helen lewis is a is a
british
writer she said that
you know called coronavirus i don't
remember exactly the
the words he she chose but the
coronavirus artisan
was a disaster for feminism because of
all this you can see different uh in
different
uh degrees but violence is one thing
that has
been really really global i don't know
the numbers
in in in china for example but uh
certainly was the case in europe and in
latin america there was a big rise
all right i have to tell you related to
chile that as we are debating
our new process we are all thinking
about our future
which policies how much state how much
free market
how do we reform capitalism in the way
that serves all citizens and not only
companies we're all in
this is our normal talk besides kovit
because we are facing this
this process and because in the next you
know two years we only have elections
we're going to elect
conventionals for the to write the new
constitution governors
mayors uh and then we have a party
we have to change all the parliaments
and then their presidential elections so
uh the political debate is very
important and even though
we have the highest people capital latin
america
i don't know if you yeah we we can say
that
um the way we have
uh done this development has left
a lot of things uh you know
uh not addressed so inequality for
example so even though chile was very
very successful in taking
people out of poverty out of 17 years of
dictatorship
when you know pinochet the dictator left
the country with almost 50 almost 50
percent of war people
without democracy without social
cohesion with fear in a country that was
nothing compared to what is now uh
you know chile in this 30 years was able
to put people out of poverty to create a
bigger middle class and to do a lot of
great things to
of course has a stable democracy
you know with full rights and all that
but a lot of things were left behind and
now
you know what chilean people want is to
you know to
to the the pace of movement and reform
be a little bit faster so that
you know all the citizens are served by
this democracy and not
only the privileged ones so uh so that's
that's
why in some things we look more
developed than other countries of the
region but in other ones
i think it's not the case and uh in
inequalities toward women we are not one
of the best
ranked countries in in the region not
even before government 19.
okay thank you paola uh really it was
an amazing presentation with a lot of
things to think about
and i would like to end by
exchanging ideas on action items
what can we do what can we do as
individuals
what can we do as collectives what can
we do as
a society to alleviate this crisis
thank you claudia i think it's a great
question and
i will go back to the inspiration of the
of the beginning of my presentation i
think what we have to do is to be
together and and be
you know uh to work and
showing we are all in the same boat so
it's
not be divided so i think the most
powerful
force on earth is sorority you know uh
part of the matismo and the patriarchal
culture
is dividing women creating these fake
rivalries
and this you know and seeing the other
women as a competition and not as
as someone that is suffering the same so
i think the first thing is
when we were all together in that march
millions of thousands and thousands of
women in the streets
we we we achieved something together
and then we when we were able even with
all the crisis
to succeed in in having a gender parity
written constitution
was a huge success one last testis
created this performance but also women
all over the world they dance it even in
turkey they were you know put in jail
for doing that but they were okay we're
here we are together
that's the first thing claudia and i
think we need more cooperation
between our countries in the region
because we are facing very similar
realities
and uh and to not you know be on
solitary fighting for themselves for the
individual not only for me it's for
all of them and especially for the ones
that are coming
what i want is my country to be better
for my
for my daughters and for my
granddaughters you know and also for my
grandson i mean it this is a not fair
place not for women but also not for men
you know uh
ruth bader ginsburg died and she was
quite an inspiration for all women all
over the world
because you know she said this way when
we are treated
differently on the basis of sex or
gender we say now
this is bad this is uh this is a very
uh this is affecting the constitution
this is destroying the constitution but
also is bad for
men and women so it's a new way of
seeing the world and
being together i think it's the only way
and not accepting
anyone trying to divide us you know
divide women
we have to be together and be strong and
then we have a strong voice a voice that
like la stezi's voice really is going to
be heard all over the place
thank you i want one last question that
just popped up
in the q a that i think it is related to
this last
answer what can yale students do to get
involved with solving issues of gender
violence during the pandemic
well you have a great group that is
called yale women right
i remember when i was at the yale world
fellows uh
program i was invited by young women and
by other groups
at the school of management they were
also yale women so i think yale has a
very strong community they have
all these groups i was so amazed to see
how students and
academics and teachers they they were
together having these lunches having
these initiatives
so that to debate things i think that
maybe all
ada women or one of the
different organizations that i met when
i was there
might take a look at which countries are
suffering more i
am certain that in the us might be the
same case you are you have so many
challenges
in in the moment in the u.s not only
related to covet because
also the you know the presidential
elections if so many things but
violence against women is something
universal so maybe debatable that have a
task force
uh of different students from different
parts of the world you have a very
diverse community
uh geographically related and and all
that
and see maybe uh there's an initiative
that y'all can say at least
with all the numbers for example to see
the figures to put okay this is
you know a very uh well done diagnostic
about what is happening with violence to
women
and uh i think the first thing that must
be done is to make this visible and
relevant and then yale can do a lot
because it's one of the greatest
universities in the world
yeah thank you i completely agree with
that
proposal and with that i thank you so
much
and i represent the audience
uh with my applause i paola's
been an amazing opportunity
and and really an honor to have you
in being the the one launching our
series
thank you so much thank you claudia
thank you thank you daniel thank you all
the teams thank you kleist macmillan
center
and uh well i hope to see you you know
some future to debate about this and to
tell you what happens happening in chile
with this parity gender party
constitution
when the kovid allows us to travel again
but
you know in my heart part of my heart
still is there so
thank you it's been an honor you are
part of the yale community thank you
you